[Music]
at 5 44 on your Monday morning what's
driving you crazy well not a complete
shutdown of the I-15 but there are two
upcoming overnight closures of the
Northbound freeway lanes part of the
I-15 Tropicana project maybe we'll just
call this one drop a can of Junior the
first of those closures is tonight
starts at nine Northbound from Blue
Diamond up to the 215 Southern Beltway
you're going to be diverted East on
Windmill up Las Vegas Boulevard to the
215 on-ramps baton Square that's the
access to get back onto the north 15 so
not a huge deal crew is going to be
putting in an overhead sign supposed to
be finished by five tomorrow morning but
a heads up also they're going to be
doing something similar next Monday on
the Northbound Lanes at Russell Road
please share this with anybody who might
be affected now the online version of
this toys on our website when you click
traffic then driving you crazy buckle up
drive carefully please put down that
phone you can join the driving you crazy
conversation at traffic eight at
eightnewsnow.com